l'avantagent du moteur à vapeur c'est
bien sûr d'avoir de l'eau chaude à
disposition mais aussi de faire tourner
une turbine qui propulse un très joli
bateau
l'aiguillé
c'est un
emploi
parce que vous voulez c'est magnifique
si je lui souhaite beaucoup
ici c'est pour le thé et le café
comme ça
et ici nous avons la chauffage et il ya
beaucoup
pour marc delestret
construit en 1990 le zara fine reprend
le principe du bateau anglais du début
du xxème siècle un type de navigation
remis au goût du jour par un marin
ingénieurs anglais passionné de
motorisation à vapeur
l'angleterre a une longue histoire nous
avons inventé les machines à vapeur
naviguer avec ce bateau c'est ma manière
de maintenir cet héritage et de le
transmettre aux jeunes générations
une passion partagée par sa lady slater
qui a fini par adopter ce drôle de
bateau le bois est magnifique avec le
vernis
aussi
c'est pas les mots mêmes et par le
moteur les salles entre les pistons
comme ça comme ça comme ça c'est bon
même si le zara fine effet pour la
tamise où les rivières anglaises la
puissance de la vapeur lui permet
quelques démonstrations sur la loire
[Musique]